you had a conversation with jordan
peterson
where he asked you a question
in terms of war being last resort
whether you would like your kids to grow
up
in peace in a time of no war
you said yes but and so happens jordan
didn't let you finish
can you um can you elaborate what
follows the butt
well you you and i have been talking
about the fact that struggle
brings people together and and brings
out the best and
and the worst brings out the worst in
people war brings out the worst people
it also brings out the best in people
so would you want your kid
to go and enter in a wrestling
tournament
where you paid all the
other kids off and your kid won
or you enter them in a jiu jitsu
tournament where
they're a purple belt and you know that
everyone that they're gonna fight
against is a white belt
and so they get the they get the big w
they get the win
but they don't really get tested and
they don't really struggle and if you
don't struggle you don't grow
so that's the butt right um
the the absolute best
times of my life
were in combat and the worst times of my
life
were in combat and so even though i
wouldn't want any of my children to
suffer through the worst of times
at the same time the bud is i would want
them to
have the opportunity to feel that bond
that you're referring to
earlier and to see human beings
that are willing to sacrifice their
lives for their friends
you